so you've obviously spent the last
nine ten years uh building gumroad
um you've made a couple of angel
investments along the way
but now we're gonna dive kind of deeper
into investing
uh one maybe talk a little bit just
about some of those angel investments
you made
how they went and then why focus on
actually putting together a fund and
going and kind of being more
uh organized and serious about the
investing activities
yeah so i did just a little bit of angel
investing
previously especially before gum road i
did five
deals before governor when i was at
pinterest and that was really for me to
build
like a mental model of the industry
right i was like okay i'm a founder
i'm an early employee i was an early
employee i want to be a founder at some
point
one great way to learn about this model
is to basically take the money i didn't
give usc and invest into startups
so i did i invested in five companies uh
in 2011
uh two of them did quite well hello sign
ended up selling to dropbox for 230
million
and one movable ink is gonna do
something pretty well as well and so i
had
just like from five i'd had two good two
good hits and so that was like okay i
have some sensibility some taste maybe
here
uh and then i did my sixth deal was
lambda school i did 2017 there's seed
ground that's also
looks like it might be good we'll see
again like
you don't really know right it's it
could be massive it could go to zero
uh but that was an interesting bet um
and then in 2019 and 2020 i did a bunch
more like 10 or 15 but
it's been too early to really say what's
going to work but i did figma
clubhouse house uh the apertife brand
uh circle this new crater community
thing
um squad like but just a bunch of small
smaller small ones that are just so
early to
really know if they're going to work or
not um but i have some sort of like
some track record and like some interest
in really learning about
about this this kind of space because
it's it's fundamentally important like
if you're interested in startups like a
lot of the startups do raise capital
they do raise money from vcs and angels
and and and there aren't that many
people who are those people and so
like you can be a meaningful part of
like business creation engine
uh you know if you participate in that
so that's kind of how i thought about it
and then i did after the george floyd
stuff i i there was that meme going
around about
higher wire and i was like i can do
these i could hire
people and i did and we'll continue to
do so and i can also write checks and so
i just tweeted out this is the power of
twitter uh you know i just tweeted out
hey i've
done some of these investments i'm
looking for more i'd love to invest in
black founders
and i did four deals from that and two
others since
indirectly um and basically i just run
out of ran out of money like i can't
i don't again i don't have picture stock
i don't i'm not
uh you know i still pay myself like a
salary i haven't sort of exited any
liquidity on the government stock side
so it's not like i have a ton of money
um but you know i did a few deals and
i and some of them were looking for more
money so i emailed a few friends
including the ball i was like hey
i did a couple deals you know you want
to co-invest in these they're looking
for more
more money and he he effectively just
says you know like i'd love to just give
you money and then you can just choose
where you want to invest in i'll pay you
to do that and help you sort of advise
you on that
uh so like let me know if you're
interested like we have this new product
at
angel list called rolling funds sort of
like lowers the barrier of entry as a as
a fund manager you can sort of try it
out ping a few friends i'll anchor you
you know you can start at like a hundred
thousand dollars a quarter do a couple
deals a quarter
and then you know see how it goes and
you can use twitter you can
do whatever you want because it's kind
of this new model
um that's a little different than how
it's been done in the past and i was
like oh this is interesting like i'm not
going to be a full-time vc
i don't want to deal with any of that
stuff and i don't have the time i don't
want to go on like this
road show for months uh or zoom show now
and uh but i can you know i can send
some emails and these things right so i
so i talked to angellist set up like a
little rolling fund and
uh put together a brief memo on an ocean
that's just sort of like my track record
who i
am like what i'm interested in uh my
little fun strategy and just send it out
to
you know 50 100 people did a webinar
about it
a couple tweets and now i have over a
million dollars a quarter committed
so it'll be it's a sizable it's a
sizable fund it'll be a four million
dollar a year fund or something like
that which you know
if you have a normal fund with all these
different things that's sort of the
equivalent of like a 12 million 20
million dollar fund depending on how
much you allocate for follow-ons and
walk us through the math um i know
you've done the math in terms of like
how that works but
walk us through like if you raised a 40
million dollar fund previously like
we're talking earlier
uh yeah do the math of how that works
yeah i mean i was kind of mind blown
because
even though i'd raise money from vcs and
things and been an angel like i never
really
knew what what are the economics of the
vc right
and so i yeah i was like 40 million fund
that is you know first of all you're not
investing the 40 million you take a
typically take a 2
management fee over 10 years so that's
20 gone so you're really investing
32 million dollars uh then typically
half of that or two-thirds of that is
often reserved for follow-on capital for
this sort of the first rounds of these
companies
their second and third etcetera rounds
uh typically it's pretty common
one one to one or one to two ratio so
let's be conservative let's say one to
one
so that's half the capital so 16 million
is going into early stage
first round of these companies and then
that's over
many years often right so that might be
over three years typically right three
to five years or something like that for
a fund of that size
so really that 16 million is split over
three years it's around five million
dollars a year
right so this 40 million dollar fund
that i see this big announcement i'm
like wow i would never do that that's
insanely massive and like it's
probably so wealthy and making all this
money and they can do all these deals
you know and i'm like wait that's like
[ __ ] like five and a half million bucks
five point three three three million a
year into new companies
like that's that's that's a very
different like five to
forty that's a huge difference right so
i just started doing the math and i was
like wow like i can
with the rolling fund which like
dramatically makes it easier for me to
to do this and because of twitter and
the sort of
the sort of direct to sort of invest lp
kind of relationship i can have with
everybody
uh because that's kind of my stick like
i can raise a fund that's you know
probably on the size of a lot of these
early stage funds but it's part time for
me i can
and i don't have any overhead right 100
of my management fee i'm just putting
back into the company into the fund is
lp capital
so you know of the 4.4 or whatever i'm
at now per year like
you know basically besides angel lists
fees that's all going to go to companies
uh so over 4 million would go straight
to the companies
uh and uh and and that's it
right you know like it just keeps the
model incredibly simple you don't have
to do any math on like
any costs to the to the fund in terms of
like dinners or
employees or associates or an office
space or any of that stuff like i don't
need any of that right like all i need
is um
some money goes into an ageless bank
account and then i
talk to companies and say hey can i give
you money and then if they say yes
i just you know do a cc and then the
deal gets done and i think that is going
to be really interesting over the next
few years like kind of being early
that same idea i just i just like as i
when i
discovered this and i talked to naval
about it i was like i was like this is
really interesting and like i totally
imagine in five years
there are going to be hundreds of these
people like what i'm doing now who are
having these rolling fonts able to
collect you know commits
on a quarterly basis able to do it
publicly raise any time raise anywhere
and you you know like i wonder what that
does to like sort of traditional
sandhill road clearly sandal road's out
of commission right now with
cobit right but like i wonder if like
this is just the end of it
right like why would you why would you
need to if you can just raise from all
these people
you can do it over resume you no founder
wants to raise money right like even if
if you're you want to go down the vc
route it's a necessary evil still right
uh and so i just think if you can if you
can get coalitions of these
founders operators people who actually
understand
sort of what it is to be a founder or
have some domain expertise
i i just think that that sort of the
career vc again
like it's a curve it's not like a binary
instance
it's on its way out it's been on its way
out for a long time you saw this with
syndicates you saw this with super
angels
you saw this now with rolling funds my
guess is over time
the sort of traditional partnership
model is
going to go away uh and you see it in
politics right like i think politics is
a really interesting analogy because you
have
bernie sanders and trump who basically
can race
directly from people they don't have
their their teams are tiny they have
incredibly low overhead they're super
scalable
and they they can use it as a as a
marketing thing like i don't have to do
super pacs i don't have to have dinners
with rich people behind closed doors
every two years
which is what vcs do right like that's
what vc's have this like two-year
fundraising kind of
process they talk to all these rich
people
you know that i don't i still don't know
most of their names like i kind of
people have been like oh you should you
know and i'm like oh i didn't even know
they're all these people out here
a lot of them you know they're like
they're like family offices a lot of
them are in like
china like the money it's not as it's
not as like
sort of like a bunch of tech people
giving other tech people money there's a
there's a lot
there's a lot more happening uh that
i've sort of started learning about
but you know a lot of them have access
right so like you know if
if some family office writes you a 10
million dollar check
into your fund to anchor you like you're
gonna have to
you know give them updates right you're
going to have to kind of give them some
things have a call with them
once a month which is actually not that
dissimilar probably from politics right
like there's probably some soft
commitment
that if you if you bundle and you get
you know
you give the you know clinton campaign
or the biden campaign or the trump
campaign or whatever
like a million bucks they're gonna pick
up
the phone call right uh and so there
there's like interesting to see that
kind of play out so my guess is just
like in politics you're gonna see way
more aoc's way more bernies way more
trumps
right i don't know if that's good or bad
like not a
statement on that just it's just gonna
happen like that's what i believe
and that's the beauty of democracy and
like things you're just gonna get
demo you know people want democracy and
they're going to get right inevitably
uh and uh and i think the same thing
will happen on the on
on the venture side which by the way i
think you know this whole conversation
about diversity and inclusion
like a lot of founders they race from
vcs these vc's raised from lps these lps
look very you know there's a there's a
path right
uh uh you know that sort of that cuts
through harvard and stanford and i think
if you can have all of these fund
managers from all over the place from
all different backgrounds
and all the levels of domain expertise
all having these
small funds you know like that's just
better
for everybody there's like more diverse
lps more diverse founders more diverse
gps
more diverse employees like i i see this
all the time like i'm
you know a dude i like started a company
and like
people you know like like women will be
like you know it's weird that like this
company i worked at like did this or
didn't do that and i was like holy crap
i had no idea i didn't even know
that's the thing that women would want
or not want or whatever you know i just
had so little context for it
uh like tampons in the bathroom like
it's so cool and i'm like oh [ __ ] that's
a great idea
like i didn't i wouldn't have thought of
that obviously i was 21 at the time a
little different life experience now so
i know some of these things but
but uh i just think it's so much better
to just give people
money to go solve the problems that they
would know about then try to spend all
this time
you know trying to like learn about this
thing it's like no i'd just rather give
you money and you can go solve it right
and i think the same thing with these
with this sort of like the the venture
capital kind of community is like all
these
all these funds are trying to do all
these things but i really think the
answer is
just like give people a bunch of money
and then like they'll do it
they'll do a great job they'll do a
better job than you reading 10 books and
a bunch of blog posts
and then trying to solve the problem
like that you just don't know it's not
it's like like i can talk about indian
culture i've never lived in india
but like i just know it because i've
i've learned i've just grew up in that
sort of environment right and and just
it doesn't matter how awesome you are
like unless you have like a
a master's degree you're just not gonna
know as much as i do because of all the
little things i picked up
and it's kind of like that right and so
i just believe so much in like
a bunch of diverse lps picking a bunch
of diverse
gps and those gp's picking a bunch of
diverse founders and those founders
building companies that are just better
at all these other things solving all of
these different problems
and i'm just i'm super excited about it
because i do think it's going to be like
a really interesting trend that's going
to lead to a lot of interesting
interesting companies in the next you
know five to ten years